manifestation sous haute tension au
tchad
une semaine après la mort du président
idriss déby des protestataires se sont
rassemblés dans les rues de n'djamena la
capitale
un rassemblement à l'appel de plusieurs
partis de l'opposition
il dénonce le conseil militaire de
transition dirigée par mahamat l'un des
fils du défunt président tchadien
une manifestation non-autorisée
rapidement dispersés par la police à
coups de gaz lacrymogènes face aux
méthodes des forces de l'ordre certains
habitants ont exprimé leur colère et
leur incompréhension
si j'ai la bonne mémoire il oldie les
doigts de manifestations sefyu dans
l'air dans les rues qu'on avait dit dans
les textes qu actuelle mais me suis
surpris à 4 à 5 heures comme zola
lacrymogènes pas tous des enfants les
innocents pour la pluie
aulas l'écouté vraiment y suis choqué
c'est pas digne d'un gouvernement
il faut il faut il faut légèrement test
c'est pour lesparre a revendiqué
d'autres divisions
le dialogue n'est ce pas et donc c'est
normal c'est normal que la population
puisse se soulève et se soulever contre
la position de la france paris
particulièrement attendu à propos de
cette prise de pouvoir controversée
emmanuel macron a reçu ce mardi à
l'elysée le président de la république
démocratique du congo
les deux chefs de l'état ont fait part
de leur préoccupation face aux violences
et à la répression grandissante dans le
pays
nous appelons respect des engagements
qui ont été pris par le conseil
militaire de transition
celui d'une transition pacifique
inclusive sur le plan politique je suis
pour une transition pacifique
démocratique inclusive
je ne suis pas pour un plan de
succession et la france ne sera jamais
aux côtés de celles et ceux qui forment
ce projet au niveau africain
nous avons cet objectif de faire taire
les armes
voilà pourquoi je ne me lasserai jamais
de sensibiliser la communauté
internationale par rapport à des zones
de violence en afrique
je suis plus que jamais déterminé à
l'éradiquer et je compte sur le soutien
de la france
le nouvel homme fort du pays ma mathy
driss débit s'est exprimé ce mardi dans
un discours télévisé il a promis
d'organiser un dialogue national
inclusif durant la période de transition
de 18 mois le président du conseil
militaire de transition a néanmoins
évité d'évoquer les violences qui ont
éclaté dans le pays